so but there's there's such a vast
number of guys I recently had a I can
say the former police officer come up to
me and he is now medicating with
cannabis now he's retired one of the
interesting things that he said to me
and I think it's been about 90 days now
that he's actually been experimenting
with it
was that he has the ability to kind of
contemplate where he is in his life
right now
and he said I realized that I was an
[ __ ] and I kind of chuckled I said
well I've known you for 10 years I've
known you hey there's no idea I'm I'm
that way - my family - and I realized
I'm not spending the kind of quality
time with my kids I should be spending
here's why would cannabis make me think
that way I said Allison as long as
you're having great thoughts I'm not
sure why that happens to keep happening
keep doubting him he needs to spend time
with his more with his kids to begin
with and so this gave him a whole new
conduit his wife is still in law
enforcement so there's kind of been some
pushback there but he has been on nine
different pain meds over the last 14
years and so he said his big issue was
he would have these swings of depression
depending on what meds he was taken and
he said I I recognize the depression as
a chemical response to the meds I was
taking so I never he does know I'd never
was like I'm going to commit suicide
today but he said I would be depressed
about how this sucks I hate you know I
hate my life right now I hate everything
about it but I understand why I feel
this way mm-hmm yeah so he goes that's
why I never really killed myself he said
until I started doing cannabis because
I've walked away from all those other
pills so he doesn't take anything else
Zippo just just cannabis cannabis that's
that's that's awesome
so it's well it's amazing that when you
start looking at it when I had initially
gone to true leave which is a dispensary
here in the state of Florida when I had
gone over